you can see the economic decline
throughout the capital Belgrade Sonya me
Socko says the suffering is tangible
this is good
both she says serbia's elite is pushing
for EU membership as the way out of the
crisis but in her view it'll take more
than economic reforms to get over the
wars and atrocities committed in
serbia's name in the 1990s the accession
to you
his condition by also dealing with the
past and between covers an issue sooner
or later but really what we are dealing
with here this society denied
not back in the mid-90s basado
co-founded the Helsinki Committee for
human rights in Serbia in opposition to
former President Slobodan Milosevic the
nationalist dictator was ousted in 2001
elections in 2012 returned some
proponents of greater Serbian
nationalism to power but nowadays they
want to be in the EU well this is it's
not easy emotionally to accept the fact
because they really stood up for the
worst and especially in a pleasure to a
party a progressive party they were the
feast of malicious policy in Bosnia
Croatia that includes the party leader
and deputy prime minister Aleksandar
vucic the most powerful man in Serbia
says he's changed here he's passing out
certificates for winners of a school
competition butit's promises the
up-and-coming scientists a future in
Europe just over six years ago he was a
staunch nationalist as a member of the
Opposition he wanted to have a Belgrade
street renamed Ratko Mladic boulevard
after the Serbian general known
worldwide as the butcher of the Balkans
it's a way to show that we will fight
for freedom and that we love and
understand Serbia and the Serbian people
and today
the rest of guys
the wheelchairs like
now the reformed nationalist says he
wants to modernize Serbia and lifted out
of economic misery during the election
campaign voting had to be pulled forward
in three districts because old
coalition's collapsed ahead of time the
reforms within each and every one of us
but we'll live better and no one will be
stealing from you and no one would grab
from you we will build a tolerant
society of those who want a decent and
normal Serbia but political groups
further to the right are critical of
this approach in their view the
government is bowing to EU pressure by
tolerating the independence of the
former Serbian province of Kosovo with a
Brussels agreement wood chips betray the
Republic of Serbia and our national
interest and he gave up Kosovo words
like that make human rights advocates
Anya be Sadko wonder if anything's
really changed in the evening she meets
an old colleague vodka povitch ovitch
both say they have little confidence in
the new leaders and that they hope the
EU keeps up the pressure